there's times when the Dean doesn't
really enjoy being herself but she's
such a cool character
what's a trait of hers that you would
love to possess yourself her wit and her
sass I do respect it I mean I think
obviously sometimes she goes a little
overboard but I mean she she definitely
is set in her ways with with certain
things and I I do admire that about her
the fact that she will set her mind to
something and stop at nothing to to get
there I think that's that's something
pretty cool about her although I don't
like to call out in particular that it's
a female director because it should just
be a regular thing I can really tell
when it comes to the female
relationships in this movie especially
the mother-daughter that it has that
woman's tongue so great oh I'm so glad
that you said that yeah totally I mean
it's um I think all the characters are
be so beautifully drawn and directed and
depicted in this film but I definitely
think yeah it's absolutely true I mean
you cringe but then it breaks your heart
but then you're angry but then you're
happy with it I mean it's it is it's
very real I mean I thought it was one of
the best scripts I've read in decades
I'm I just thought it was perfect it's
incredibly important to talk about how
hard it really is to be a teenager and
and it also really beautifully depicts
how hard it is to be a mother it was
refreshing you know you get a lot of
scripts that are like this genre this
genre and this kind of broke the mold of
coming-of-age stories for me I couldn't
put it down when I was reading it felt
like I was reading somebody's diary but
the characters aren't black and white
they're not just bad or good they all
have they all are real people and aren't
stereotypical and have and have reasons
you kind of see throughout the course of
the movie that each character has
reasons for the way they are that's what
I like I know I could definitely relate
to this movie when I was watching it
yeah what did you relate to in the
script that were just always our lives
are constantly evolving and that we're
constantly figuring things out I mean
you can take the story of Nadine and put
it in anywhere you know it could be a
period piece it could be in college it
could be in a new workplace it's just it
works anywhere is timeless you know and
it's that universal thing the universal
human condition that we're constantly
trying to fit in and we're constantly
trying to be just not anonymous we just
want to be somebody you turn into a
completely different person
you actually love being part of that
exclusive little group I'm having a
problem today maybe
you